[Music]
hello and welcome and welcome back to
sophie covisionaries me sophie sheppard
nate this is our second half of in-depth
conversation with brilliant mind
complete genius nobel prize winner
professor gerhard hoft talking about
whether quantum mechanics and quantum
physics is just a probability and more
of an esoteric notion rather than a
precise science
it looks as if the whole universe was in
its simplest possible form when
everything got started
and all that needed to be done as
someone to pull the switch not literally
but um
well metaphorically and then the
universe starts expanding
so where are those equations come from
and uh and who pulled the switch that is
not the kind of question that science
can answer
where is it that the micro world ends
and the macro universe begins where is
this well it's not true of these two are
totally different worlds in fact they're
all just one world so all those stars
and planets that are roaming around in
our universe they're built of the same
particles that we study in our
laboratories and the smallest units of
matter so the smallest units of matter
make up everything so if in principle if
you know exactly what the laws are that
move these particles around then we can
understand how styles and planets are
made how galaxies are made of styles and
so on and in fact how the whole universe
is made so there's no fundamental
boundary between those worlds if you
throw it dice very carefully you'll know
how to make
two sixes right
i mean a very agile magician might be
able to die such a way that he always
gets two sixes if he knows exactly how
the dice works very hard with the
principle possible so
that's what we want in quantum mechanics
as well we think there's something
underneath that says there's no
statistics at all quantum mechanics is
just
a
a bad language of something that's much
better but we don't understand what it
is
if you're saying that there is no dice
and everything is actually predicted and
even a magician
if he's a really good trained one can't
put a dice the way that it is six if he
wants to then does this mean that there
is no place in this universe for a
chance
no quite the contrary as i said the
particles that the world are made of are
so complex
that some of their properties will be
forever unpredictable it's too
complicated and certainly it holds a
human brain i can't possibly predict
what you're going to think next it's
hopeless you can't even try but quite
generally speaking there are so many
particles in this universe
that you can't predict what they are
going to do even though their laws may
well be deterministic they are simply
too complicated and this is not a little
bit too complicated but fundamentally
far too complicated for us to predict
exactly what they are doing but more to
the point is we don't even have the
right language to do so so the quantum
language we do use is so much
suited to the idea of making statistical
predictions that using that language we
can't even say for certainty where a
particle is going so we need to modify
our language and i'm convinced that this
is something in in our future of in the
future of science to figure out a
language that doesn't need statistics
not for particularly
for the aim of trying to predict better
than anybody else what's happening
because i fight many particles forget it
you can't predict how they all go so
as soon as you say that there's room for
a chance because you can't predict that
these particles are going so you can't
predict what the outcome of some
experiment is there's a meteorite coming
the speeding in our direction you can't
know in advance where it will hit the
earth it's way too complicated so forget
it but what i don't want to forget is
the idea that there should exist laws
that tell you that that tell every
single particle exactly where she's
going not approximately
in all decimal places exactly where the
particle is going
but we don't know those laws and today
it's impossible to formulate such laws
because they're using the wrong language
so when you're saying that uh
i've heard in one of your interviews
you're saying that there is a level of
reality of physics that is even deeper
than the quantum mechanics is this what
you mean are you talking about the
language exactly what i mean
that there is a language where you don't
need the
fairly familiar quantum concepts for
this according to quantum mechanics it
looks as if
our universe is is actually only one of
many universes it looks as if there's a
universe of universes that's the way the
equations are
i i
construct it
but it's wrong i don't believe there are
very many universes i think there's just
only one all those others are universe
that didn't materialize because the
probability was just they were just too
important they happened not to happen
only one universe came out as the
universe that we are in and we can
calculate the probability if we would be
able to do the calculation with infinite
precision that probability would be one
and all other probabilities would be
zero but we can't calculate with
infinite position hopeless we shouldn't
even try so we find this universe is the
most likely universe from our
perspective doesn't mean that any other
universe exists or so or that no other
universe could exist but there is only
one but you know how
most of the people believe that universe
is endless and uh
a lot of
professors actually claim and believe
that too and i was reading the nature
astronomy magazine
article and they were saying
they had this supposition that actually
universe might be
might not be endless for instance if you
were to start walking in one direction
that eventually
eventually you would come back home
could that be true i mean
what do you make of it and if our
reality has borders
suppose that it has borders what is
beyond them
so um
i sympathize a lot with a theory that
says the universe is bounded in the
sense that the surface of the earth is
bounded right in ancient times people
thought that if you travel in one
direction on earth you'll
you'll end up in new countries forever
you'll never return but now we know the
unit the the earth is a sphere if you go
fast if you're far enough you end and
end up at the other side of where you
came from and you're back home
so i would like to
envision that the unit that also the
universe that we live in is just like
that you go in one direction you will
return from the other side and what's
beyond it and so there is nothing beyond
it
because there's no other dimensions than
that they're interested here you're
looking at
on planet earth in two dimensions it's
it's it's rounded and it's a sphere but
there's a third dimension which is
height elevation above the ground and
that still seems to be in an infinite
dimension
but that's only because we don't
we don't know about
the universe being
returning to it back to itself
the equations we have for the cosmos
certainly allow the situation in
principle so they allow the notion that
the universe is like a great big sphere
but in one dimension higher than the
planet earth so that also the concept of
height
is included in this picture so all three
dimensions will return when you go
faster far enough
that's in principle possible and i would
find that more satisfactory as a theory
of the universe but i can't tell god
what to do so maybe the reality is
something different but but
for me for me it would be very pleasing
to see a theory where the universe
itself is also completely finite in that
sense then you don't need any boundary
just like there's no boundary anywhere
on the planet earth to say
you can go to here but not any further
well some places are somewhat difficult
to walk into like antarctica but that
doesn't mean that antarctica is is
slightly different from the rest yes
um i don't know if you've heard your
korean colleagues scientists they have
recently suggested that dark energy the
thing that actually expands
our universe
may not really exist
dark energy is one of the deep puzzles
of today's
cosmology science of the cosmos
einstein
when he
introduced general relativity he already
noticed there's one term in that you
could add to this equation and that term
would modify the shape of the universe
and in the beginning he needed a term
then he realized he could do without
that term so i said that was an error i
should have never introduced that to him
but it is an einstein who's going to
tell whether that term is there is
experiment experimental observations
and then
for some decades there were experimental
observations that accumulated saying
that there is a very small
constant in einstein's equations that
tells you that there's something that
you now call dark energy
and the equations work much better with
dark energy than without
but
now recently
cosmologists were saying that they have
overestimated the accuracy of their
previous observations there could be
some effect that wasn't taken properly
into account in the beginning
and so
the
conclusion that we had
drawn previously that there is such a
term as einstein prediction predicate
might be wrong and actually that term
might be zero
i would find a theory much more
understandable if that term was zero so
there is no
but if even if that term is zero that
would still be a problem
because
the next question would be why is it
zero why did nature forbid such a term
and
uh it's just because of my lack of
fantasy i can't imagine any other value
than zero for that term because if this
is if it is the value that the cosmology
said
i would have a big difficulty
understanding where that value comes
from because it doesn't fit with all the
other numbers in in the universe it
doesn't fit with the forces that
particles have on each other it doesn't
fit with our theorem gravity very well
it's just there
you know annoying us
so it's it's it doesn't look right
but
i can't
come with more valid objections than
that my only objection is i don't like
that term i wish it was zero that's not
good enough for any scientist so they'll
all look at me and they'll they'll just
say okay you said that now we just
continue
and
so
i think it it would be more satisfactory
as a starting point that the universe
has no such term
but
eventually i don't know even if there's
no term i would out
need more understanding as to why there
is no such term and this also we don't
understand today
professor we're going to take a short
break right now when we're back we'll
continue talking to professor gerhardt
at hoft talking about the way universe
functions stay with us
[Music]
and we're back with nobel prize winner
professor gerhardt at hof talking about
the universe professor
when i was a kid
it was still soviet union
and cosmosis was like a huge thing we
had cosmonauts americans at astronauts
they were national heroes
and
i think like every other soviet kid
including myself i wanted to be a
ballerina or a cosmonaut
it was this complete not even a dream it
seemed like it was our future
it seemed like everything that was up
there cosmosis is where we're gonna end
up all the literature that we read
that we loved so much it was about that
and then the quantum physics
in
you know again with it and we're
thinking this is it you know we
understand everything so the next step
is up there
40 years later the only thing i
understand that
we're definitely not going into cosmosis
we know nothing about it
um
we still don't know so much about the
quantum physics the only future that
actually turned out to be my present is
smartphone and virtual reality
do you think
that my generation i mean how long am i
going to live another 40 years maybe
with luck i'm just bound to the virtual
reality or there's still a chance of me
stepping on some planet out there
that's that's a good question
i don't know i also thought that
the space technology will develop faster
and that
by 2020 that
i was also a kid i thought 2020 is so
far away by that time you'll be walking
around from my eyes
or venus or whatever
and
you'll be running around in spaceships
all the time that hasn't indeed
materialized it's a lot more difficult
than people realizing in the early days
um
and the same for nuclear energy by the
way i thought all energy would be
nuclear and it wouldn't be able to we
wouldn't need to pollute our atmosphere
with carbon dioxide because it wouldn't
burn fossil fuels we just use nuclear
energy
so why don't we do that
and
it all means that the questions are more
difficult than originally realized
i also think that
i would i'm also surprised
that um
artificial intelligence didn't develop
faster than it actually is doing i
thought but by this time all computers
will be at least as intelligent as human
beings themselves and um
that also did not materialize
i think some of these things will come i
think that um
the castles well not literally the
castles that he talked about just but
our integrity our extension to deep
space do you still think it's possible
what do you call deep space the solar
system
can be reached for you some beautiful
planet in the orion constellation
well wait a minute don't go too fast
okay mars
our solar system has a bunch of objects
which are suitable for human life in
principle
and they'll be probably very
uncomfortable unless technology improves
a lot
you'll have to be able to make very
expensive
homes on on those places and i think in
principle technically it's possible
we've already sent our robots to mars
and many other places in the in the
universe so
all they have to do is make make a
decent house to live in and all the
comforts that we need as humans and then
we will travel there and you'll
inhabit the entire solar system
eventually
these things are possible in in time
span of 50 or 100 years or something
like that
but there's another thing you mentioned
a planet somewhere in oregon that's not
a story because these are really far
away
those stars are tremendously far away
and
it it takes probably thousands if not
millions of years
for a spaceship a man-made spaceship to
reach those other planets you can't put
a human on there because they will not
survive for a million of years even if
they are asleep they won't divide
survive that so because there's too much
radiation and and all that sort of thing
so um it's
going to
be very very difficult for humans to
travel that far i don't think that will
ever happen
but
robots eventually will go there
the first thing robots will do is they
they colonize our planets they are doing
it already with mars and the moon there
are things landing there all the time
and they do the investigations still in
a way this is very primitive
in the eyes of someone say a few
hundreds or thousands of years from now
they'll say now we really know how to
send robots anywhere and these robots
will be smart enough to build
houses for humans to live in
and then the humans will come after
those robots
this is the way i see it those robots
might in millions of years of time be
able to reach those other planets but
i'm talking about millions of years so
that's that's a long time for any human
standard
but it's short in terms of of the
universe in terms of evolution
a million years ago we were monkeys but
that that is nothing in evolutionary
terms life was a thousand times or more
earlier than that
and
has developed all time so
in phase of evolution a million years is
not much
so if that's the time scale we have to
use and that will be the time scale at
which even humanity eventually will
reach the other planets but
not before that
okay two more questions left first of
all where is the quantum computer that
everyone is claiming is going to be here
well if not tomorrow the next week for
sure well
i have a slight problem with the quantum
computer because it is claimed
to be able to solve problems which no
other classical computer can
but i'm saying at the same time that
eventually the laws of nature should be
just like the classical laws
so logic should be classical logic and i
believe in that which means that
something must go wrong with the quantum
computer
and
but in practice the quantum computer can
still
work very well because when things go
wrong they go wrong at a very very tiny
distance scale and time scale
so tiny that for all practical purpose
the quantum computer will function
we will need quantum mechanics to
describe it and it will do miracles
compared to ordinary computers like what
like solving difficult problems
difficult
material problems
search problems finding things which are
impossible to find
a code breaking is a very interesting
application for for computers they can
fracture
very large numbers into their prime
components much better than any
classical computer can these things will
happen when
um
that i don't know i'm not really
like within the quantum computing
business in your
in your view about humanly
a couple of decades or so okay that
computer computers will be able to do
very specialized tax tasks better than
other computers but most tax
tasks i don't believe will be done
better background to computers so i
think they should continue working with
you know constructing old-fashioned
computers because in practice they will
be much better
and also you know we humans we
are talented we invent beautiful things
but then somehow we managed to make out
of those beautiful things
horrible things do you think that
quantum mechanics could also be
weaponized
i think
practically anything can be weaponized
so
that's an awful side effect of science
that our enemies can also use it our
criminal enemies
and they can do crimes with science
dictators in other countries can dictate
the people using science
yes that can happen there's nothing we
can do about it but we want to use
science to
to better human lives is possible to
enable humans to do things which would
otherwise be impossible you just asked
about colonization of outer space
without science that's unthinkable
so
so yes
that's the way we want to use science
but we can't prevent that others will
use science in a way that we don't like
we are not under control we can't
just tell a dictator not use science to
you know suppress his own people or
things like this
professor who thank you so much for this
amazing in-depth talk about the universe
and how it works
wish you all the best of luck
with your future inventions and openings
and looking forward
thank you very much thank you
[Music]
you